how big of a deal was it for you cole
and baby to be on a record together at
that time it was fine especially for
for north carolina right because but i
felt for me like at the time
um
i feel like it was fire but at the same
time like man i'm in the middle don't
nobody know the [ __ ] i am but that's why
it was dope for you yeah no it was
though it was they're like yo this guy
who's this [ __ ] guy lou so i'm like
man i don't know how i don't know how
people are going to react to this
because i'm like you know you got cold
you got the baby and then you just got
this guy in the middle but the responses
was fire like i loved it
and then you got
you got a grammy nomination from that
which is a [ __ ] big deal yeah
were you there when uh
chris bosh was pulling up with beats yes
bro that was trippy as hell like to come
around the corner and you see chris bosh
in the corner making beats and [ __ ] and
they were fired right better than chris
webber's beats have ever been yo this
was fine